hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an episode called a small town
from the drama fantasy series the
twilight zone
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the episode starts as the tv news
reports the death of littleton town's
mayor trina grant the news pays their
thoughts to the friends and family of
the mayor
trina was instrumental in turning the
town into a lucrative tourist spot but
the new mayor john conley is in favor of
extending the nearby freeway and cutting
the town off from it conley isn't well
liked by the community as he never
actually won an election and only got
the job based on the succession law
cut to a year later littleton is in
terrible shape the lack of tourism has
caused most of the townspeople to go
broke the sole exception is mayor conley
who owns the bank and drives a flashy
sports car
trina's widowed husband jason grant now
lives in a church's attic working as the
church's handyman a teenager named
emilio brings supplies to jason and
shows jason his drawings of the town's
mayor
as they talk emilio asks jason the
reason for him living in the attic it
turns out that jason never fully
recovered from his wife's death and now
prefers to spend most of his time in the
church attic rather than his own home
citing trina's suggestion to be closer
to god
later that day jason gets permission
from the church's pastor michelle to
clean out the attic
while cleaning out the back corner he
finds a large model of the town and
props it up on two stands
he turns a key on its side and lights
within all the model buildings flicker
on and off he is fascinated by its
precise details but becomes unnerved
when he looks into the church's window
and sees a small figure with his
resemblance inside
he shrugs it off and sprays some water
on the church to clean the dust off
it suddenly starts raining outside
the following morning jason has
breakfast at the busy bee diner he talks
with anna the diner waitress and
emilio's mom
then he hears two men talking about
yesterday's reign they find it weird
that it only lasted for a few seconds
and hit only one block of the town
he then hears anna telling emilio they
will be painting the diner tomorrow so
jason heads back to the church and uses
pastor nichelle's peach nail polish to
paint the model diner the next morning
the town wakes up to a new peach paint
job on the diner nobody knows who did it
which upsets anna at first but she
eventually warms up to it since it
cheers the town up as jason quietly
takes pride in his robin hood-like deed
he sees an old woman trip in a pothole
he rushes to her aid the old man beside
her tells jason that they had put in a
request for the mayor to fix the pothole
a long time ago but the town's new mayor
conley doesn't even look at it so jason
takes the suggestion box home with him
to fix the town's problem himself
jason goes through each suggestion and
fixes many things around the model town
for every pothole and tree stump he
fixes it immediately fixes itself in
real life
he even tests the model's power by
putting a chicken bone on the model
street a life-size chicken bone appears
on the real street which feeds a barking
dog the town reacts positively but they
start to suspect mayor conley is behind
it all due the upcoming election season
this irks jason especially because he
hates the mayor
after much pondering jason decides next
to build a model sign declaring
littleton as the most magical small town
in america
he places it on the corner of the model
the next day hundreds of travelers exit
off the road and the town flourishes
again
jason attends pastor nichelle's morning
service where she talks about the
mystery helper who has been dubbed liu
dante as a prideful jason plays with his
gold wedding ring a churchgoer loudly
theorizes the helper is conley conley
who is at the service does not deny it
but accepts the townspeople's gratitude
regardless a furious jason plots revenge
on conley so he drops a pebble on a
model car
the next morning the town wakes up to
find a meteor has totaled conley sports
car
he furiously demands any information
then sees emilio laughing he grabs his
notebook and sees he has drawn his
smashed car
conley verbally attacks him causing an
angry anna to defend her son
conley regains his composure and speaks
charismatically to the rest of the town
a rousing speech ends with him calling
himself liu dante drawing applause from
the crowd and an angry stare from jason
later that night jason places a
tarantula in the model town around the
same time conley is taking a leisurely
stroll through town a huge
building-sized tarantula creeps down the
street and petrifies conley as a
satisfied jason takes the spider off the
model the giant version gets pulled up
into the sky
a visibly shaken conley looks around but
finds nothing
emilio paints a large multicolored
spider on the wall the next morning
a paranoid calmly sees it while walking
down the street and demands answers from
emilio anna steps in once more and
angrily tells conley to talk it up with
her if he has a problem with her son
pastor nichelle checks in on jason one
night they discuss the town's recent
turnarounds and jason insists hanley
isn't the mystery helper
michelle corrects him and says anyone is
capable of good change even the most
stubborn ones
he stops terrorizing conley and returns
to his good deeds now adding more lights
to the littleton sign
while the new sign reappears and shines
bright it drains too much electricity
and the town loses power
an emergency town meeting is held in the
church the town's people are obviously
panicked and demand conley to fix it he
fails to say anything causing the people
to accuse him of trying to kick everyone
out of town for a political agenda
he cowardly leaves the church and spots
emilio across the street drawing into
his notebook conley grabs it out of his
hands and shows the town his drawings
linking the boy to every recent bizarre
happening the town starts diving into
chaos with most of them demanding
solutions from conley with no other
choice jason steps in and finally admits
to being behind everything he insists he
only wanted to help the town while
calmly nearly destroyed it to prove it
jason goes up to the church attic and
places his engagement ring beside the
model mentally apologizing to his wife
for letting her down
he then lights some matches in the
street of the model
this causes a bonfire to appear in the
real street conley and the sheriff
intrude on jason and witness the model
in action
conley gets evil thoughts and ponders
turning the town into the new vegas with
the model's powers he demands the
sheriff to take it jason fights him for
control causing them to bump into the
model
an earthquake outside erupts as the
three fight and accidentally knock the
model off the stands
the following day we see anna jason and
pastor nichelle walk in the streets
jason says the model is now broken so he
has no way to re-establish the town
however his engagement ring has landed
in the town
in real life it is huge
they figure that the massive ring will
provide the money for the town to be
re-established a nearby newscaster
reports it is one of the largest pieces
of gold ever found suggesting that the
town will flourish
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching